so we had Gideon here and I asked yeah I
don't like I asked him personally like
what that [__] was he gave it when he
was on the pot within the last day no no
no you guys they beefed afterwards
they be at Manchester Gideon was at
Manchester yeah but they'd be prior to
that and then they beefed again
afterwards there was no beef dog I mean
what happened at the fight
Gideon went ape [__] on my brother I
texted him because I was friends with
him I said I think you went a little too
far if you ever want to handle something
with Jake just call me dude there's no
reason to like go at his exes like he
like he went from zero to a hundred on
my brother no but break down the whole
[__] because like you did you were you
were sitting on the couch you were home
I don't know but you did call him a
[__] or some [__] like that way when
you called him a [__] you were sitting
next to Jake and some other people oh no
it was a
better the fight
I call him a [__]
broke it down on the fight and he was
like Hey you came at him and that's why
he responded hold on can I pee
it was Logan hold on hold on
you guys keep going if you need to so
why does he feel that why are you
calling him two-faced explain the whole
thing it's it's first off
I hate giving this narrative any [__]
fuel because I don't give a [__] I just
don't
um we're at a UFC event
he was sitting next to us and there was
a camera a live streaming camera in our
face
I didn't feel like being live streamed
God strike me down so I politely asked
him very politely and this is all on
video I never called him a [__] he's my
friend we work together with prime I was
like hey bro do you mind switching seats
with me just so you could face the other
way because I just don't feel like being
live streaming all night please don't be
mad at me Judy on it this is the coming
from a nice place I don't really I'm not
good at like messaging whatever I said
it was like polite yeah I think it
rubbed him a little bit of the wrong way
because like and I get I get content
creation especially being like a young
Creator he's he's in the heat of it dude
and he's doing great his numbers are
great yeah he's got a he's got a loyal
audience W's in the chat for jidion
um and so I think it may have I think it
may have broken
hey dude like like you know I'm I'm out
of it I'm out of it I'm not daily
vlogging I'm not doing the live streams
like I value the time and privacy I have
with my girl at these events that we
come to a lot
I think it rubbed him the wrong way a
little bit then he snapped on my brother
and like people can say that I'm a bad
brother and all this [__] but like you
know I only have so much tolerance for
people who are talking [__] about Jake
like including Bradley Martin recently
who came out in Texas
so I texted Judy I was like hey bro I
think you went a little too far with
Jake hop in the phone I was like if you
ever want to clear anything up and he
like apologized whatever and because he
was talking about
uh his acts and all the all the deepest
cuts you could go for with Jake he did
in one live stream but this was a mutual
X right no it was Jake's it was Jake's
it was it was like the the controversy
back then anyways anyways I think both
of those things which I can say
confidently I was within reason
I don't I don't think either of those
are like
out of the ordinary kind of rubbed in
the wrong way so when this Dylan [__]
started coming out and by the way that
was the extent of my conversation with
Gideon then when this Dylan Street
started coming out Gideon's stoking the
fire with Dylan [__] get back on
Twitter you're the funniest guy ever and
I'm so I'm in my head I'm like
you worked with us with prime you've
been on my podcast we're friends we have
open dialogue I even gave you advice
with some stiff stuff in your career
because of these two things that I think
were very reasonable
why are you completely flipping to
someone who is an evil human especially
as a person who has is as
supposedly good virtue as judeon is he's
a good guy why choose Dylan [__]
Dennis
an actual evil human okay why so that's
why did you ask him for that
I didn't ask him I was in Manchester and
he's like he's like he and I knew this
was gonna happen he was backstage he
chirped him he's like hey Logan can we
switch these real quick real quick he
was like trolling me in person and I was
you know I don't know
this press conference I just threw a
cake of Dylan Dennis his head act Dylan
Dennis yeah and I was just like yo you
two-faced and he's like yo dude what are
you okay
won't be rude with KSI and I just I
didn't understand what he was saying and
he says he doesn't need to be real with
me because I'm not real but I've only
kept it real with jitty on
I don't I don't know the young man I
think you guys need a connecting yeah I
do need to go because he's a good guy
yeah
I'm just saying I asked him and I'm
asking you and like but it sounds
different story I never called him a
[__] until three days ago ever he felt
Justified to respond in the way that he
did that's insane today
because even when after I did that he
goes through the deepest cuts he can
what's the deepest cut just like just
saying just saying deep deep like bro
I'm I've done a lot I'm roastable you
know there's there's some things that
you can you can say and some things that
you know like all right I'm I'm going
for his [__] jugular and he did that
like what you what are you doing going
zero to a hundred you know like
it's he's he's
he's a young Creator I think he's I
think I'm not even I don't give a [__]
bro I'm not even gonna come I have no
business I'm trying to assume what's
going on in his life we need to have God
bless him God bless
No cameras no nothing dinner together